REALLY START REALLY WORKING ON
LOWERING PRICES.
>> Sean: I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
PLANET THEY'RE LIVING ON BUT
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
THEIR PAUL, A VAST MAJORITY OF
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
DISAGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT.
83% NOW DESCRIBE OUR ECONOMY,
RIGHTLY SO, AS POOR, NOT GOOD AT
ALL.
HEREWITH REACTION IS THE HOST OF
THE MONICA CROWLEY PODCAST,
MONICA CROWLEY, ALONG WITH
FORMER MASSACHUSETTS -- JUST THE
OPPOSITE IS TRUE, ISN'T IT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEIR SPIN PUTS THE GLOSS ON
REALITY WHEN IT COMES TO WITH
THE POLITICS INVOLVED IN THE
NEED TO PUT A CERTAIN SPIN ON
THINGS, BUT THEN THERE IS
OUTRAGEOUS BLATANT LIES, WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS WHITE HOUSE
IS DOING AND WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
UTTERLY SINCE DAY ONE,
PARTICULARLY ON THE ECONOMY.
YOU CANNOT PUT LIPSTICK ON A PIG
AND THEN CONVINCE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT IT'S SOMETHING OTHER
THAN A PIG WEARING LIPSTICK.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE LIVING
THIS CATASTROPHIC ECONOMY EVERY
SINGLE DAY, SEAN, THEY ARE BEING
SQUEEZED BETWEEN SKYROCKETING
INFLATION, RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES, AND A DROP IN REAL
WAGES.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING EVERY DAY TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND IF THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE.
WHAT YOU SAW FROM THE
SENATOR TODAY, SEAN, THAT KIND
OF CALLOUS DISREGARD, THAT
CAVALIER ATTITUDE ABOUT HIGH GAS
PRICES, I'M JUST IN MY ELECTRIC
CAR.
THIS IS LIKE A MODERN VERSION OF
MARIE ANTOINETTE, INSTEAD OF LET
THEM EAT CAKE, LET THEM BUY A
TESLA.
AND ALL OF THIS INDICATES THAT
IT IS ALL INTENTIONAL.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO WORK TO
ALLEVIATE AMERICAN SUFFERING
HERE, BECAUSE THEY COULD CHANGE
TOMORROW, IF THEY WANTED TO.
PARTICULARLY ON ENERGY POLICY,
BUT THEY WON'T.
SO WHAT THAT TELLS YOU IS THIS
IS ALL INTENTIONAL AS PART OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL TRANSFORMATION
OF THE NATION.
>> Sean: AND THAT'S A GOOD
POINT.
IF THAT'S THE ALARMIST CULT
ASPECT THAT I TALKED ABOUT AND
THEY'RE ALL INDOCTRINATED INTO
IT.
SCOTT BROWN, AMERICANS ARE
REMINDED EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT
WHAT THEY'RE HEARING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE IS AN OUTRIGHT LIE,
EVERY TIME THEY GO TO FILL UP
THE GAS TANK ON EVERY STORE THEY
GO TO, THEY ARE PAYING A FORTUNE
MORE THAN THEY WERE PAYING EVEN
A YEAR AGO, SO ALL OF THE DASH
ALL OF THE, YOU KNOW, B.S. THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO PADDLE IN THE
NARRATIVE THEY ARE SELLING IS
NOT GOING TO FLY.
>> IT'S NOT FLYING.
I JUST DROVE END, I PAID $5.05
AND THAT'S FOR THE CHEAPEST GAS
I COULD FIND ON THE WAY INTO
MANCHESTER.
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, DIESEL PRICES
ARE THE HIGHEST THEY'VE EVER
BEEN AND SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT DAYS
IN A ROW, AS YOU KNOW, IT'S
GOING UP, UP.
WE WERE ENERGY INDEPENDENT LESS
THAN TWO YEARS AGO, THE
ADMINISTRATION MADE IT CRYSTAL
CLEAR, YOU REFERENCED IF THEY
WERE GOING TO DO AWAY WITH
FOSSIL FUELS AND CRUSH THE COAL
AND OIL INDUSTRIES, WHICH THEY
ARE DOING, THEY'RE DOING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO DO
SO.
THEY ARE TRYING TO REALLY SHAPE
THE ECONOMY TO GO INTO A GREEN
ECONOMY, AND IS NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING BECAUSE HE WANTS THAT
GREEN VOTE.
ALL THE AOCS AND ALL THE OTHERS.
RESPECTFULLY TO THE SENATOR,
LISTEN, SHE'S A
MULTIMILLIONAIRE, SHE PROBABLY
PAID CASH.
THE AVERAGE CITIZEN CAN'T DO
THAT, YOU CAN'T FIND A CHEAP
HYBRID CAR BECAUSE BY THEN THERE
ALREADY, YOU KNOW, NOT RELIABLE,
AS YOU KNOW.
AND WE CAN DO BETTER.
WE SHOULDN'T BE HAVING TO GO TO
VENEZUELA AND ACTUALLY
SAUDI ARABIA ON HER KNEES
BEGGING FOR OIL.
THIS IS AMERICA.
AND THE AND THE VICE PRESIDENT,
THE ADMINISTRATION, JANET YELLEN
ESPECIALLY, INFLATION, THE
BORDER.
I MEAN, WE COULD GO ON AND ON,
WE GOT TO GET OUR ACT TOGETHER
HERE.
I'M HOPEFUL THEY WAKE UP SOMEHOW
AND IT'S GOING TO BE IN THE NEXT
ELECTION CYCLE.
>> Sean: I HOPE SO.
THAT'S COMING SOON.
THE NEXT